what's up hustle ambassadors instead of
writing an email today I'm feeling a
little lazy so instead I'm just going to
give you a little tour of our office
ready
all right we decided to move in
to this house I gotta wait for these
cars across this house instead of an
office because we thought it was a
little more exciting
so let's go inside
okay up the stairs
here's our sticker
if you have one
or if you don't have one let me know
we'll send you one
[Music]
of the office history
we're doing some reorganizing
so the chairs are all over the place
Jackie say hi hi
here's our new conference room that
we're still reorganizing
stickers everywhere
I don't feel like writing an email so
I'm just going to send a video
oh here's Kendall he's writing the
emails that you read
that this is going to the hustle
ambassadors oh what's up
they're still doing gross stuff hold on
here's our editorial calendar can't see
that there's intern Kyle Say Hi Kyle
just say hi hi that's good and here we
are
we just got this new setup
so there it is this is your hustle
Ambassador email for the day peace